the beasts have risen and after the
explosive end of the newest Transformers
movie it seems that the world of robots
in Disguise will never be the same so
what does the film's mid-credit Stinger
mean for the future of the franchise
stick around to find out but be prepared
for some Major Spoilers the latest
installment of the Transformers
franchise introduces the maximals and
terracons to a live-action setting
giving the Autobots plenty to explore in
this throwback outing set in 1994.
there's still plenty of space in the
timeline between rise of the beasts and
Michael Bay's Transformers movies
meaning there are ample opportunities to
further explore this world where giant
robot battles have become commonplace
rise of the beasts certainly gives fans
of the series plenty to look forward to
while the Autobots emerge Victorious at
the end of the day it's clear that
Unicron is still out there and there's
no shortage of ways and reasons for the
planet eating Behemoth to return
additionally Hasbro apparently has its
eyes set on creating a Cinematic
Universe the film ends with main
character Noah Diaz going in for a job
interview but there's more going on than
meets the eye Noah is handed a card that
says GI Joe implying a crossover project
may not be too far off it's a major
development to end the film on but
audiences shouldn't leave right after
the reveal while there's no post-credits
scene there is one part way through the
credits that shows how an Autobot that
was presumed dead will be sticking
around for the time being the names
Mirage come on give me a little give me
a little give me a little give a little
tap tap there you go now we're friends
during the climactic battle Mirage who's
friendliest with Noah throughout the
movie seemingly sacrifices himself to
protect his new friend just like he
promised Noah's brother he would to give
Noah at least somewhat of a leg up on
battling Scourge Mirage turns himself
into armor for Noah essentially
providing him an Iron Man suit that
allows him to fight alongside the other
Autobots from that point it's unclear if
Mirage actually lost his life but the
med credit scene reveals the truth the
sequence shows Noah in a garage with
reek Tariq know is simply working on a
car with a funky color palette but when
Noah asks the car to reveal itself it
takes the form of a newly rebuilt Mirage
the autobot somehow managed to survive
the brutal beating he suffered from
Scourge suggesting that he'll be back in
any rise of the beast's sequels it's
obviously hard to kill in Autobot and
even if you do that might not really be
the end after all bumblebee dies early
on in the film only to be revived via
Energon during the final battle it's not
stated if Mirage also received an
Energon boost to make it out alright by
the movie's end but his survival will be
welcome for fans of Pete Davidson's
vocal performance in 2007's Transformers
Sam whitwicky forms a bond with
bumblebee who becomes a prominent player
in the movies going forward the bright
yellow Autobot even has his own
self-titled spin-off as the films go on
it makes sense to introduce new Heroes
for audiences to fall in love with and
Mirage seems to be exactly that no one
could ever take Optimus Prime's place
but it's nice to have some fresh blood
in the mix to keep things interesting
Davidson brings his signature over the
top comedic sensibilities to the
Forefront of the character who instantly
takes a liking to the new protagonist
even if Noah starts working for GI Joe
Mirage can remain his Autobot Ambassador
allowing him to call on them for
assistance when the next world ending
threat presents itself plus given the
grandiose nature of Optimus Prime it's
nice to see other Autobots are a bit
more down to earth there are numerous
places for the franchise to go moving
forward but for now you you can always
re-watch rise of the beasts at a theater
near you